i feel like as a mother you should want
to put your kids happiness above your
own i think um i think at no point sorry
um i think once you have children you
have to understand that it's no longer
about you you have to become selfless
and um yeah your children are paramount
how realistic is that in these days in
are um i don't know
i don't know i just i just think you
feel like women are taking are putting
their happiness before their children
definitely most definitely i think most
definitely i think a lot of women
nowadays if you want to say modern day
women they're very materialistic you
know very very materialistic it's like
what you said we're more likely to be in
debt and things like that yes i guess
we'll want to go get our nails done get
our hair done stuff like that you know
the vanity aspect of things whereas um
men
primarily wouldn't be doing that yeah
you know going back to what you said as
well a man would be more like okay i'm
going to work my children need to be
taken care of is there dinner on the
table that type of thing but with women
it's a bit different